whether you're exploring a data set for
the first time or
summarizing the findings of your
analysis to an audience
you can use data visualization to make
large complex data sets
easier to understand and internalize on
this episode of bigquery spotlight
it's all about visualizing your bigquery
data
[Music]
data visualization is a tool that helps
you turn your complex data into
compelling stories
unlocking the insights that both you and
your audience need to steer decision
making
using dashboards or infographics for
example can help spark and guide
discussion while the group explores the
data together
however data visualization is not just
for communicating with decision makers
it is also an important part of the
exploratory analysis phase
seeing data in visual form helps you as
an analyst identify patterns
outliers trends or other interesting
data points you want to investigate
further
choosing a data visualization tool comes
down to understanding your needs
first consider your use case are you
performing basic data visualization and
reporting
or more advanced tasks such as data
modeling
secondly you'll want to balance the cost
of the tool against its feature set
and its learning curve fortunately
bigquery is connected with several
visualization tools
including those across the partner
ecosystem so there's sure to be one
that's right for you
today we'll introduce two of these tools
data studio and connected sheets
both give you the ability to create
quick ad-hoc data visualizations as well
as dashboards and reports
let's take a closer look at each one
first up data studio
google's business intelligence and data
visualization platform
that lets you build scalable serverless
interactive dashboards
data studio has two main components the
first
explore is a place for you to quickly
derive insights from your data during
the exploratory phase of data analysis
it can be accessed directly from
bigquery just click
explore and data studio from your query
results page
data studio will automatically launch
and create a direct connection to the
query results
you'll land in the explorer interface
where you can create quick
visualizations through drag and drop
functionality
on the back end data studio is creating
sql queries in bigquery to support your
exploration
in real time in fact you can also use
explorer with a bigquery table itself
rather than query results which means
you don't need to write
any sql at all just select the table and
click export and choose explore and data
studio
the visuals you create and explore can
be exported into the reports component
of data studio
data studio reports provides a canvas
for bringing together visuals into a
dashboard
report or infographic they're easy to
share
embed and publish plus you can make them
interactive for your viewer by adding an
option to filter or select a date range
directly in the live report
data studio is a great pick if you want
power with flexibility
and don't mind taking a little bit of
time to get to know a new tool
plus it's available for free if you're
looking to wipe away the learning curve
pretty much completely for you and your
collaborators
you can do so with a second tool
connected sheets
connected sheets allows you to analyze
and visualize your bigquery
data up to billions of rows directly in
a google sheet
so if you're a user of spreadsheets you
already know all you need to know
you can access connected sheets right
from your bigquery table or your query
results by clicking explore
with sheets this will open up a new
google sheet with a tab
that has a direct connection to the full
bigquery table
your connected sheet shows a preview of
the table which can be explored by
sorting and filtering
you can also reference the connected
sheets in charts
pivot tables and functions which then
use the entire bigquery table in its
calculations
in order to support these functions
connected sheets
runs queries in bigquery on your behalf
you can manually request the query to
run by hitting apply
results of those queries are saved in
your spreadsheet for analysis and
sharing
you can also schedule data to refresh
automatically
a quick note on availability connected
cheats is a feature available only for g
suite enterprise
enterprise for education and drive
enterprise account customers
i also want to mention looker a data
platform which is now part of google
cloud
we recommend taking a closer look at
this tool especially if you're seeking
an enterprise-ready solution that
delivers business intelligence
capabilities
powers operational workflows with data
and enables organizations to build their
own data applications
there's a lot to learn in the field of
data visualization as you gain
experience you can learn to create more
effective visuals
use them to tell compelling stories and
fine-tune your design skills
and we hope that the data visualization
tool will be just that
a tool and not any additional mountain
to climb try out data studio and
connected sheets from your own bigquery
sandbox project
you can connect one of your own tables
or even a table from the bigquery public
datasets program
for a refresher on how to set up your
own sandbox and access our public data
sets
follow the link in the description below
if you want to learn more about bigquery
check out the rest of our playlist and
don't forget to subscribe to our channel
on youtube for other great content
look out for our next episode of
bigquery spotlight and remember
stay curious